yovan I had to just call man I heard how
many times you ran out of gas are you
some type of goddamn idiot ring oh and
she's calling cuz I have I've ran out of
gas in my life over 30 times because I
didn't know and I've mentioned this on a
past episode I didn't know people don't
run out of gas they don't tell you that
[ __ ] when you're growing up you know
there that's one of the problems they
don't have a class at school that tells
you things things you need to know you
know you can't you can't eat you can't
have as much soup as you want or it'll
start coming up and filling up in your
throat you can't just go forever on the
first amount of gas you get you know you
can't babysit kids and lock them in
their rooms you know they don't there's
a lot of stuff that they don't tell you
and they don't have a class on that [ __ ]
so yeah I didn't know that you couldn't
run out of gas and I have done it before
I appreciate you calling onward
once you get down to a quarter just feel
the [ __ ] take up how many times you
gotta call somebody for help man damn a
lot of times actually I've called a lot
of people for help and it is weird when
you call them for help for running out
of the gas because people think that
it's something that doesn't happen
anymore because I guess maybe it doesn't
happen anymore but let's hear more I
just smacked that goddamn mud off your
[ __ ] head I love you man I would
smack you out of love of course [ __ ]
Jesus Christ do like people don't oughta
gasp like that man you don't just run
the car to the [ __ ] it's out of gas
dude come on if you risky you do it boo
boo and I stay risky out there cuz who
do you want think about this though and
I appreciate your calling you got a
pretty voice and you sound cute but who
do you want you want a man out there
that's riding around with a full tank
all the time or you want that that mad
musket musk musk man out there who's out
there fuming and zooming you know out
there pedal-to-the-metal with nothing in
the tank maybe a cat that's what you
want I'll pick up a hitchhiker
cuz I don't want to die alone son you
know what I'm saying I want to be out
that's okay maybe that's the kind of man
you need a little bit
you need to quit riding around with
these fellows they got the full tank and
got you know a concern you know water in
the back and a flashlight [ __ ] a
flashlight I got three matches if we
don't see it after I light those
[ __ ] then it's gonna get us
because that's all I have but I'm that
wild ride you know I'm that loose can
you come in here man you like that the
sugar you're like um you're like the
Sugar Ray Leonard of compliments you hit
me in and say something sweet
cuz Sugar Ray Leonard seemed like a
sweet man you know if you look at him he
very sweet man if you hear him speak in
person very kind man but that man could
kill you and she sound like that she
sound like something sweet that could
kill you you know she she sound like
that diabetes right there you're goddamn
tanker it's not that hard and I
appreciated you're right it's not that
hard to fill my gas tank up and I'm
gonna try to do it more often and
actually yesterday I was down there like
about 17 miles and I stopped and filled
it up instead of taking that risk and
taking that chance what's up guys
sitting here with this marijuana plant I
think also could be just a regular plant
it could be poison ivy Brahma but to
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clip since you're already
here you know I'm saying